[Musik]
Deutschland liefert Kampfpanzer des Typs
Leopard 2 an die Ukraine eine
Entscheidung die manche für zu zögerlich
hielten sein Vorgehen hat Olaf Scholz
heute im Bundestag verteidigt es wäre
ein schlimmer Fehler in dieser Frage
allein vorweg zu marschieren sagte der
Kanzler für einen schlimmen Fehler hält
linke Politikerin Sarah Wagenknecht die
Panzerlieferungen an sich damit ließe
sich Deutschlands in den Krieg mit
reinziehen stattdessen sollte die
Regierung den Druck für Verhandlungen
erhöhen sagt sie
Strategieberater und Autor Dr Daniel
stelterwandt Deutschlands Wirtschaft
große Konzerne wandern ab Firmen suchen
die Zukunft im Ausland die
Bundesregierung Rede aber nach wie vor
alles nur schön ein fataler Fehler sagt
er schwere Zeiten erleben generell viele
Deutsche zu wenig Bewegung keine Lust
das sind auch die Folgen des lockdowns
motivationscoach Detlef die Soße weiß
wie wir den inneren Schweinehund
überwinden und wieder fit zu werden um
langfristige gesundheitliche Probleme zu
vermeiden Journalist und Julian Marius
Plutz begrüßt die fanzelieferungen sagt
wir müssen der Ukraine beistehen
gleichzeitig warte davor Sippenhaft für
alle Russen zu nehmen das Opernstar Anna
netto bei uns nicht mehr singen darf das
hält dafür falsch Kunst dürfe kein
haltungswettbewerb sein eine
Haltungsfrage das war für viele auch der
Umgang mit Corona und den lockdowns der
entscheidende rki-chef spielte dabei
eine große Rolle regelmäßig hat er mit
dem Gesundheitsminister die Bevölkerung
auf harte Maßnahmen eingesprochen
gemahnt gewarnt das Virus sei für uns
alle eine große Gefahr die Politik
verhängte immer härtere Maßnahmen
darunter bundesweite Schulschließungen
Kinder wurden beim Rodeln verfolgt wenn
sie keine Maske getrunken Kinder mussten
zu Hause isoliert werden verloren
wichtige Schulzeit und wichtige Zeit mit
ihren Freunden viele leiden bis heute
schwer darunter brauchen Therapien und
jetzt die große Kehrtwende lotharina
sagt im Interview mit der Zeit die
Schulen hätten offen bleiben können er
schiebt den Fehler jetzt auf die Politik
sagt aber auch er vor allem zu Beginn
der Pandemie nicht optimal kommuniziert
und er hätte mehr Gespräche führen
sollen Frau Wagenknecht sie hatten sehr
früh eine kritische Positionen zu den
Maßnahmen wenn Sie das jetzt hören muss
das Konsequenzen haben ja ich würde mir
wünschen dass das auch vielleicht mal
Konsequenzen für den Gesundheitsminister
hätte also natürlich erst die ersten
Schulschließungen kamen da waren noch
Merkel in der Regierung gab aber
trotzdem danach war Lauterbach ja einer
der schlimmsten Scharfmacher und es
wurde immer den Leuten nur Angst gemacht
und die lockdowns wurden mit
fadenscheinigen Begründungen
durchgesetzt dann später 2G auch der
impfdruck in den Schulen auf die Kinder
die die Masken das ist ja alles aufrecht
erhalten worden und natürlich ist es
erfreulich wenn wenigstens mal einer
sagt wir haben da großen Mist gemacht
aber ich finde trotzdem das ist alles
noch voll völlig folgenlos geblieben
also wieder ist jetzt weg Lauterbach ist
da die meisten die damals auch in den
Medien wirklich ganz übel gegen
Bevölkerungsgruppen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollten oder den Lockdown
kritisiert haben die die in eine Ecke
gestellt haben als wissenschaftsfeinde
als unsolidarisch die sitzen alle in
ihren Ämtern und diesen alle völlig
unbeschadet also ich finde da muss
tatsächlich auch mal eine Aufarbeitung
her der muskelkret eine Aufarbeitung hat
dann viele Familien haben diese Zeit
Herr Soest noch in ganz bitterer
Erinnerungen die Zeit für die Kinder die
zu Hause saßen aus sie sind Vater wenn
Sie diese Zeit erlebt ich habe ja drei
Kinder die sind jetzt 12 15 und 16 und
es war schon wirklich
uns in meiner Sprache zu sagen echt eine
krasse Zeit weil du warst auf der einen
Seite ganz normal Vater Elternteil du
musst es dein Unternehmen oder unseren
Beruf musst du mir trotzdem machen und
gleichzeitig noch Homeschooling und es
war nicht einfach was ich aber noch
schwerwiegender oder mindestens genauso
schwerwiegend finde ist dass die Kids
nicht mehr in der Lage waren sich zu
bewegen wenn du zu Hause bleiben musst
ja nicht jeder kommt jetzt auf die Idee
zu Hause 10 Minuten bei Fitness zu
machen und das hat ja auch seine Folgen
ja es ist nicht nur so dass wir mentale
Herausforderungen mit unseren Kids
heutzutage haben durch diesen Lockdown
der war sondern auch sportliche auch
physische und das finde ich dass das
jetzt mittlerweile so weggewischt wird
so lesifair dann lasst uns doch mal
wieder nach vorne schauen es ist ja nun
mal so passiert jetzt gucken wir
gemeinsam nach vorne wir können es eh
nicht mehr ändern das finde ich schon
heftig und jetzt hören wir heute an
diesem Tag die Schulschließungen die
hätten gar nicht sein müssen das sagt
Lothar wieder wir haben ihn alle vor
Augen die ganze Zeit haben wir ihn
gesehen geht ihm da nicht auch die
Hutschnur hoch wenn man jetzt hört das
hätte auch alles gar nicht so sein
müssen die Kinder hätten weiterhin in
die Schule gehen können ich erinnere
mich voran vor allem an eine von mir
hoffentlich richtig wieder gegen
gegebener Aussage als er damals sagte
das ist jetzt so das soll jetzt so sein
und das sollen jetzt einfach alle so
machen Punkt und jetzt stellen wir fest
dass er selbst eigentlich nicht wusste
was er macht dass viele Experten nicht
wussten was sie machen dass die
Politiker nicht wussten was sie machen
die die drunter gelitten haben war die
Bevölkerung und insbesondere die Kinder
und da jetzt so
entspannt zu sagen gut es war jetzt so
jetzt gucken wir mal nach vorne es geht
ja auch weiter das finde ich nicht gut
wir haben hier schon angesprochen
Konsequenzen Herr blutz müssten folgen
welche Konsequenzen müssen das sein
schreit das nicht nach dem
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag ja
definitiv sollte es Konsequenzen haben
denn ethisches Handeln kann nur
moralisch korrekt sein wenn es eine
Verantwortung gibt uns eine
Verantwortungsträger gibt Verantwortung
bedeutet Rücktritt Verantwortung
bedeutet vielleicht noch was ganz
anderes vielleicht sogar eine
juristische Aufklärung warum nicht denn
wenn die jemand hinstellt über Monate
über Jahre sagt diese Maßnahmen wie es
richtig gesagt dass Detlef diese
Maßnahmen dürfen nicht hinterfragt
werden auf keinen Fall hinterfragt
werden da fragt ich nicht was stimmt mit
diesem Menschen nicht denn man kann sich
entschuldigen ja aber eigentlich kann
man nur um Entschuldigung bitten und
wenn man das eben verwechselt oder sagt
nee das läuft einfach so weiter dann ist
es eigentlich nur ein hohes Wort
Entschuldigung ist es nicht getan das
ist konkret werden wer muss gehen was
muss genau passieren die ganze Regierung
noch mal ganz ehrlich ist über Monate
über Jahre hinweg sind falsche
Informationen verbreitet worden was
Corona angeht meiner Meinung nach und
wenn man sich dann hinstellt ja ein
bisschen Entschuldigung hier und dort
ist das viel zu wenig nein die müssen
zurücktreten ganz einfach mir bricht das
muss ich sagen wirklich für die Kinder
das Herz die folgende sind und das
wussten viele Fach Menschen schon vorher
verheerend für die Kinder erstellte sie
sind ein Mann der Wirtschaft und die
lockdowns hatten auch wirtschaftliche
gravierende Folgen weiß genau
Bildungssystem aber ich glaube ich habe
damals im Frühjahr
2011 gesprochen oder heftig kritisiert
aber mich ist schon so es ist
Staatsversagen es ist nicht nur Versagen
von einzelnen Politikern und zwar
Staatsversagen dahin gehen dass wir
immer so tun als wäre mir Gutes gekommen
aber wir haben eigentlich nach der
ersten Welle die Zeit nicht genutzt
worden ich habe damals kritisiert wir
hatten keine Tests wir hatten kein
Konzept die Altenheime zu schützen und
aber das alles versäumt haben hat man
dann eben die Kinder zu Hause gelassen
was natürlich irrsinnig wenn Sie die
Schweiz schauen und andere Länder wo sie
nicht stattgefunden hat und wenn wir
dann noch schauen dass wir trotzdem eine
Übersterblichkeit hatten wir hatten dann
deutlich Übersterblichkeit durch die
corona-krise und mal was sagen muss okay
der Staat hat im Prinzip das was er
hätte machen sollen nicht gemacht zum
Beispiel im Schützen der alten und hat
sich dann in sowohl Politik gehalten und
für mich geht es halt weiter sagen ja
sowieso sowas ähnliches machen aber für
mich ist halt wichtig bei so einer
Tanten Aufgabe war der deutsche Staat
nicht leistungsfähig und gleichzeitig
haben wir Politiker hat sich noch viel
andere Themen auf die kommen wir auch
noch vornehmen wollen Transformation in
der Gesellschaft eine ökologisch und so
weiter wo ich aber sage wenn er das
schon nicht hinbekommen ich wollte sie
für größere Sache hinbekommen das heißt
wir brauchen eine Kompetenz Aufwertung
im Staat gesamthaft nicht nur in der
Politik aber vor allem auch in der
Verwaltung und wir müssen daraus lernen
darum müssen wir systematisch
aufbereiten müssen sagen was ist alles
schief gelaufen und wie können wir
zukünftig besser machen nur das findet
eben die Stadt es wird auch bei anderen
Themen die Stadt der gerne über Panzer
reden als keine Panzer in Deutschland
fahren ist ein Dilemma
sowieso in Deutschland das Leid der
Kinder das kann man überhaupt nicht in
seinem wir wirklich einen Schaden aber
schon wenn Sie den bemessen es gibt
Studien die zeigen dass verlorene
Schuljahre verlorene bildungsjahre
lebenslang geringere Einkommen bedeuten
das bedeutet im Prinzip Leute erreichen
geringen
qualifikationsqualifikationsniveose wir
nehmen Leben lang weniger verdienen
nachdem wir sowieso schon so wenig
Kinder haben wenn wir die oder
schlechter Ausbildung es gibt ja auch
die studiende zeigen dass die
Grundschule jetzt weit zurückgefallen
sind die werden ihr Leben lang weniger
zur Wirtschaft Beilage tragen können das
heißt aber auch sie werden Niederlage
sein die Renten zu erwirtschaften die
wir gerne hätten um die alten zu
versorgen das heißt da gibt's
Folgekosten gigantisch und die
wirtschaftliche Frage aufzuwerfen weil
sie zu corona-zeiten sowieso wenn sie
gesagt hätten wir geben so viel Hunderte
von Milliarden volkswirtschaftlichen
Schaden aus um so diese Menschenleben zu
retten das ist Moral steht das nicht
verstehe ich auch für Politiker nur am
Ende ist es so wir zahlen ein sehr hohen
Preis für das schlechte Corona
Management aber nicht nur dafür sondern
viele andere Dinge die bei uns nicht gut
laufen wie hoch ist der Preis kann man
so ein wirtschaftlichen Schaden nicht
nur gemünzt auf die Schulen sondern der
der geblieben ist durch die lockdowns in
irgendeiner Art und Weise
ein paar hundert Milliarden ich meine es
gibt ja auch eine Studie aktuell jetzt
vom Institut der Wirtschaft die sagen
allein durch den Corona durch den
Ukraine Krieg aber da gab es das
Beispiel wenn wir dieses Jahr alleine
175 Milliarden Euro verlieren das sind
2000 Euro pro Kopf und ich würde sagen
durch Corona haben wir ein vielfachen
diese Schadens gehabt
normalerweise externe Krise aber wir
hätten besser damit umgehen können und
das sollten wir das Lernen für die
Zukunft dazu sagen
wir sprechen ja gerade auch über die
Gelder die der Staat ausgibt auch in
Bezug auf die corona-krise oder die
Nachwirkungen und es gibt Fördergelder
für die Nachhilfe von Kindern ja oder
von Schülern aber die zu zur Verfügung
Stellung dieser Fördergelder ist so
schwierig und so bürokratisch dass die
Kinder oder auch die Eltern gar nicht in
den in den Genuss dieser Fördergelder
kommen weil die Eltern irgendwann sagen
okay ich muss so viel ausfüllen dass so
viel Bürokratie dabei dann lasse ich das
lieber und das finde ich auch
verbrennt das kann doch nicht sein dass
wenn wir schon die Situation haben dass
unsere Kinder nicht mehr genügend
Bildung bekommen haben in dieser Zeit
dass dann das Geld was zur Verfügung
gestellt wird um das aufzuholen dann
bürokratischen Problemen untergeordnet
ist
also es war gab es ich glaube das war
die Bildungsministerin die so gesagt hat
naja die corona-lücke das können wir
nicht mehr aufholen das können wir nicht
mehr schließen da ist halt eine Lücke
und Pech gehabt so ungefähr und das
finde ich unglaublich ich meine wir
sehen jetzt wie schnell der deutsche
Staat wenn er denn will so genannte
Sondervermögen schafft das sind
natürlich alle besonders
hundert Milliarden für Rüstung man macht
2 Monate
100 Jahren für die Aufrüstung dann macht
man 200 Milliarden jetzt dafür dass man
eine verfehlte Sanktionspolitik
irgendwie Ausgleich wir sind schon
Verwandten drinnen in ihrem Zimmer da
hat man ganz viel Geld ich glaube man
bräuchte vielleicht 50 Milliarden oder
vielleicht sogar nur 20 um jetzt
wirklich den Kindern die gelitten haben
die hier auch noch Richter gestellt
wurden es sind ja meistens auch die
Kinder von ärmeren Eltern wo die nicht
mit Homeschooling und so das gar nicht
leisten können und Migration um denen
ich meine da bräuchte man gar keine
Riesensummen da braucht man nicht 100
Milliarden wahrscheinlich aber man
bräuchte ein gewisses Budget was man zur
Verfügung stellt stattdessen hat man
allen Ernstes jetzt sogar noch mal bei
den sprachkitas gekürzt das heißt das
ist dann auch für die Schulen noch mal
eine richtige Hypothek weil natürlich in
den ärmer und vierteln das ist ja
bekanntes Problem die Mehrheit der
Kinder spricht kein deutsch das heißt
statt Geld mehr zur Verfügung zu stellen
kürzt man Gelder und die Kinder werden
da ich finde das wirklich die Kinder
werden
gerade schon ihr Thema Gesicht und
deswegen gehen wir jetzt in dieses Thema
auch direkt rein denn Demokratie
bedeutet Debatte sehr nicht hinterher
gehalten mit ihrer Meinung zu den
Panzerlieferungen und da kam auch sofort
eine Reaktion und zwar vom früheren
Botschafter der Ukraine andere Menschen
der hat heute getötet und schreibt über
sie so eine widerliche Hexe Frau
betrifft sie das persönlich naja ich
muss mal ehrlich sagen das ist ein
debatten-niveau ich hoffe nicht dass wir
uns dem in Deutschland annähern sollten
also dass ein Vize-Außenminister mit
solchen Bandagen austeilt spricht nicht
für das demokratieformat in diesem Land
aber zur Sache selber also ich finde es
ist ja jetzt entschieden wir werden weil
sie ihm auch was entgegnen entschuldigen
sie dann noch mal unterbreche
ja also ich finde Herr Melnik wirklich
macht auf eine unmögliche Weise Politik
und äußert sich Deutschland hat egal ob
man das jetzt gut findet oder nicht
inzwischen über 3 Milliarden Euro
bereitgestellt um der Ukraine
militärisch um die Ukraine militärische
unterstützen vor schon vor den
leopardenlieferungen wir haben über eine
Million Menschen aufgenommen die
flüchten was ja völlig richtig ist also
natürlich bin ich auch der Meinung wäre
vor einem Krieg flüchtet den sollten wir
helfen aber das sind trotzdem sehr viel
Mittel das sind sehr viel Gelder das
sind Wohnungen das ist ja ein etwas was
dann natürlich wiederum für andere nicht
da ist und wenn ein Land sich in solcher
Weise engagiert und dann die Vertreter
der ukrainischen Regierung und speziell
Herrn Nick nichts anderes zu tun haben
als ständig deutsche Politiker zu
beschimpfen ich bin ja nicht die einzige
also das ist ja normal Herr Mütze nicht
und andere also alle die nicht seine
Meinung teilen mit denen hat er ja
regelmäßig also die beschimpfte auf
unflätige Art und Weise als ich finde
eigentlich nicht dass man sich das
bieten lassen muss also das persönlich
naja gut Hexe ist jetzt also es ist
natürlich irgendwie es heizt ein Klima
auf also ich meine wir sind jetzt nicht
in der Zeit wo die difformierung als
Hexe dazu führt dass man irgendwie
verbrannt wird das ist zum Glück
Vergangenheit aber es hat ja schon etwas
also wenn man das so was im Netzwerken
in sozialen Netzwerken da sind übel
Beleidigungen immer schon aber das soll
man offizieller Vertreter eine eines
Landes und das ist ja als Vize
Außenminister mit solchen verbal Orgien
aufwartet ist schon also für die für die
Debattenkultur ein echtes Problem und
unterirdisch also ich finde das einfach
wirklich nur widerlich muss ich dann
auch sagen jetzt gehen wir zurück auf
die Sache irgendwie wir bleiben bei
ihrem Thema sie bleiben nämlich dabei
die Panzerlieferungen halten sie für
falsch erklären Sie uns jetzt warum ja
also ich hatte wirklich war wirklich
froh nach Rammstein als Scholz zunächst
mal sagte er liefert nicht ich glaube er
hat das wirklich auch getan weil er die
Gefahren sieht die eskalationspotentiale
aber leider ist nicht so gelaufen wie
bis jetzt immer Scholz hat gezögert er
kam unter Druck von den Grünen von Frau
Strack Zimmermann von den Amerikanern
und der ist wieder eingeknickt und ich
finde das hochgefährlich und ich muss
sagen ich bin es auch leid dass mir
irgendwelche grünen selbst ernannten
wer-experten die noch nie ein Panzer von
ihnen gesehen haben jetzt ständig
erklären wie die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt und ich finde wir sollten
ernster nehmen was echte Militär sagen
also Leute die sich offenbar auskennen
also beispielsweise der
generalstaatschef der USA generell der
hat im November schon und jetzt noch mal
im Rammstein ganz klar gewarn der hat
gesagt also auf der einen Seite das ist
ja positiv hat er gesagt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die Russen die
gesamte Ukraine erobern können die sei
gleich null das können die nicht
militärisch nicht also um das zu
verhindern muss man keine Panzer liefern
aber er hat gesagt umgekehrt auch die
Ukraine dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt dass sie tatsächlich alle
Gebiete zurückerobert würde er auch
diese Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr sehr
niedrig ansetzen eigentlich ist es fast
ausgeschlossen das heißt das einzige was
diesen Krieg beenden kann sind
Verhandlungen und das hat er auch noch
mal ganz dafür hat er plädiert und was
ich so schrecklich finde dass wir uns
immer nur in dieser militärischen Logik
bewegen wir liefern immer mehr Waffen
jetzt haben wir die Panzer freigegeben
jetzt fordern die Ukraine schon
Kampfflugzeuge es gibt auch schon
Forderungen U-Boote Kampfhubschrauber
irgendwann wird man fordern deutsche
Soldaten de facto sind wir immer mehr
Kriegspartei wir lassen uns immer tiefer
in diesen Krieg hineinziehen wir müssen
ja auch die Ukraine ausbilden das wird
ja gar nicht so oft debattieren diese
Panzer kann man nicht bedienen das ist
ein halbes Jahr Ausbildungszeit sagen
Militär ist also ich bin keine aber das
wird immer wieder gesagt die Ausbildung
von Soldaten ist aber faktisch schon
damit macht man sich zur Kriegspartei
und meine große Sorge ist dass dieser
Krieg irgendwann sich ausweitet und wir
müssen doch das Interesse haben ihn zu
beenden jeden Tag sterben hunderte
Menschen es sterben junge Russen die
auch keine Lust haben in diesen Krieg zu
gehen ist sterben junge Ukraine als
Soldaten bewerben Menschen die zivile
Bevölkerung Kinder Frauen und wir müssen
doch endlich eine Friedensinitiative
Starten der Westen muss doch Druck und
zwar auf beide Seiten machen meines
Erachtens das ist Verhandlungen gibt
dass man ein Kompromiss findet dass die
Sicherheitsinteressen beider Seiten
gewahrt sind und dass man irgendwie zu
einem Ende kommt statt diesen Krieg
immer mehr zu eskalieren und irgendwann
sind wir selber mittendrin sie haben
also wirklich Sorge dass ein dritter
Weltkrieg tot also es gibt viele
Militärs die das auch so artikulieren
also er war zum Beispiel der ehemalige
Militärberater von Frau Merkel hat den
Interviews ganz eindringlich gewarnt und
es ist doch klar Russland ist eine Atom
macht und wenn man irgendwie sich also
immer stärker in den Krieg hinein begibt
an dem eine Atom macht beteiligt ist
dann läuft man genau Gefahr dass es
tatsächlich auch ein solchen
eskalierenden Krieg gibt und wir kennen
das aus der Geschichte meint auch der
erste Weltkrieg ist nicht der war ja
nicht so geplant das war nächsten
Schritt nach dem nächsten und immer
dachte man offensichtlich ja das geht
schnell vorbei oder das eskaliert nicht
so und dann gab es da so ein ein
jahrelanges morgen Millionen Tote
furchtbare furchtbares leid und ich habe
so ein bisschen den Eindruck wir
stolpern auch so Schritt für Schritt
jetzt in einen Krieg hinein den
vielleicht keiner will natürlich keiner
ich will niemand unterstellen der seinen
Weltkriegen möchte und aber ich glaube
das war schon eine Willenserklärung von
ihnen erklären
niemand ein Weltkrieg also ich meine wir
wissen nicht ob er den überleben können
er hat es ja wirklich gemacht er hat ja
die Bomben werfen lassen er hatte sehr
getan
Verkehrsunfall
das klingt so als wäre das irgendwie ein
Verkehrsunfall wir stolter die
poltereien nein Putin hat diesen Krieg
begonnen aber sie entscheiden doch was
wir machen und wir müssen doch alles
dafür tun diesen Krieg zu beenden
natürlich können wir nicht entscheiden
was Putin macht aber wir entscheiden
doch was wir machen wir entscheiden
gehen wir weiter in dieser rein
militärischen Logik wir liefern Waffen
die Russen verlieren es sterben immer
mehr Menschen es hört nie auf oder aber
versuchen wir Verhandlungen zu erreichen
es gab ja schon Verhandlungen ich meine
die haben ja zusammengesessen die
Ukraine
verhandeln kann dass man sich mit dem
Aggressor an einen Tisch sitzt man redet
nicht mit Gangstern und wie sollte man
das auch wieder soll das auch
funktionieren man erinnert sich am
Anfang macron hat sich ja gebrüstet
damit wie oft er wie viel Stunden er mit
Putin telefoniert hatte was haben die da
gemacht Kochrezepte ausgetauscht aber
auf jeden Fall hat es nichts gebracht es
war nichts gebracht und heute und heute
und heute reden wir darüber dass ein
Land angegriffen wird und noch mal es
war kein Verkehrsunfall sondern ein
Angriffskrieg und es ist übrigens auch
eine Art von Verantwortung von souverän
Staaten wie z.B Deutschland dass man
auch diesen Ländern helfen muss denn am
Ende des Tages geht es nicht nur um
Putin oder Russland am Ende des Tages
geht zum Deutschland nicht möchte das
von Deutschland von dem Laden von Europa
übrig bleibt
gerade deswegen muss man den Krieg doch
beenden ich meine wir haben auf dieser
Welt viele Angriffskriege also muss man
auch mal festhalten bei anderen Kriegen
liefern wir nicht Waffen oder wir liefen
teilweise die Waffen an die Aggressoren
zum Beispiel die Türkei oder
Saudi-Arabien also wir sind damit sehr
unterschiedlichen Maßstäben unterwegs
aber ich bin ja bei Ihnen natürlich
müssen wir alles dafür tun dass dieser
Krieg sich nicht ausweitet dass nicht
immer mehr Menschen sterben aber das
erreichen wir doch nicht indem wir immer
mehr Waffen liefern das würden wir doch
wirklich nur erreichen durch Druck in
Richtung Verhandlungen und es ist nicht
wahr dass das nicht geht es gab im
Frühjahr in Istanbul Verhandlungen die
hatten eigentlich schon relativ
erfolgreich ein Ergebnis die Russen
hätten sich hinter die Linien
zurückgezogen vom 24 februar und die
Ukraine hätten dafür zugesichert keine
NATO Mitgliedschaft keine ausländischen
Militärstützpunkte keine ausländischen
Truppen und diese Verhandlung sind von
den Ukraine beendet worden und da gibt
es zwei Theorien warum die einen sagen
wegen Botschaft die anderen sagen weil
Johnson und beiden interveniert haben
weil sie an dem Punkt den Krieg gar
nicht verwenden wollten ich will gar
nicht spekulieren wer diese
Verhandlungen oder warum sie beendet
wurden aber Fakt ist es war nicht die
Russen und es wäre ein Friedensschluss
gewesen der hunderttausende
Menschenleben hätte retten können keine
Waffen geliefert werden oder anders
gesagt wenn die Waffen schweigen von
Kiew das Putin sagt okay herzlichen
Glückwunsch wir gehen wieder zurück das
glauben Sie doch nicht im Ernst
runter entschuldigung
ich würde die Frage gerne mal ich habe
mir das auch in den letzten Tagen in
Vorbereitung auf die Sendung und
generell man spricht ja über diese
Themen logischerweise habe mir folgende
Frage gestellt Druck erzeugt Gegendruck
also wie lange wie hoch muss denn das
gehen also bis wohin auch wie Sie gesagt
haben was wird noch alles geliefert
Kampfpanzer dann erhöht Putin wieder den
Druck gibt noch mehr Waffen rein wir
noch mehr Waffen rein also wo endet das
und ich habe mir auch die Frage gestellt
wenn wir alle sagen putin ist eigentlich
nicht zurechnungsfähig ja oder man weiß
nicht was er tut glauben wir denn dass
er irgendwann aufgrund des Drucks des
Westens und der Ukraine dass er
irgendwann bisschen höher in die Hand
nimmt und sagt also sorry jetzt ist mir
der Druck zu groß können wir uns bitte
an Tisch setzen ich kann mir das einfach
nicht vorstellen
also ich persönlich ist erstmal ich
würde erstmal dazu sagen ich tue mich
immer schwer wenn man sagen jemand
spinnt also ich habe ich kenne nicht
persönlich habe
okay nein nein ich würde sagen erstmal
alles rational deckender Mensch der hat
gesagt er könnte Ukraine einstellen
gewinnt heute verziehen hat er eben
nicht gehört das ist gut dass ich gehört
hat weil ich glaube keiner möchte eine
gewaltsame Veränderung von Grenzen in
Europa haben damit ist vollkommen klar
dass wir die Ukraine helfen müssen das
erstmal Punkt
jetzt geht es sich weiter die Frage ist
was das Ziel ja was ist das Ziel ich
meine es ist die Ukraine befreit wird zu
befreien logisch wenn ich jetzt höre wir
müssen den Sieg über Russland erreichen
dann frage ich mich natürlich immer so
wie schaut so ein Sieg dann aus heißt
das wie Herr beiden gesagt hat wir
stürzen Putin was passiert denn was
passiert wenn die in Russland zerfällt
das ist ja versteht das verschiedene
Städten äh Ländern quasi was passiert
wenn es da fällt was passiert wenn wir
da plötzlich islamistische Länder haben
mit Atomwaffen was weiß ich es ist nicht
wichtig die Frage ist ein bisschen heißt
immer wir wollen gewinnen wie schaut das
eigentlich aus das heißt mein
persönlicher Sicht auf die Dinge ist
derzeit was passiert ist beide Seiten
schmeißen alles Material rein haben was
sie haben und irgendwann ist es
verändert irgendwann haben wir bei Hosen
keine Munition mehr im besten Land die
Munition nicht wer viel verschießen mehr
pro Tag als produziert wird also ist es
eine Frage der Zeit bis bei der Zeit
muss alle Leos kaputt sind bis alles und
dann gibt's irgendwie am Ende dieses
Vermögen wenn ich sogar bisschen sogar
bei ihm vorbei gibt es dann irgendwie
Waffenstillstand Frieden irgendwie
einfach aufgrund von amartung
beiderseiten das ist ein humanitäres
Desaster deshalb wäre natürlich schön zu
sagen wir liefern Leos und vielleicht
sollte man alles tun das weiter versucht
wird eine frühere wie früher einen Enden
diplomatisch das sollte man schon
Kombination sehen es denken wir weiter
was heißt das denn weiter nach ein paar
Jahren ist alles weg weil jetzt liefern
also die kaputt
funktionswege haben wir gar nicht und
dann ist es große große Thema wird dann
sein Virus wieder auf
und das finde ich wiederum eine
spannende Frage was der wirtschaftlichen
Gesichtspunkten weil ich sage ja wer
rüstet dann eigentlich Europa wieder auf
wer macht das Geschäft und wenn wir
natürlich dann sehen dass wir die
Produktion von Panzern so stark
reduziert haben weil wir keine mehr
gekauft haben in Deutschland dass wir
hinterher alles in Amerika einkaufen
müssen bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
weil das wollen das heißt für mich ist
eigentlich nicht verstehe ist warum wenn
das seit einem Jahr haben der Krieg
warum ich vor einem Jahr die
Bundesregierung gesagt hatten alle
Leopard in Gang die wir noch haben da
stehen
damit angefangen und wir setzen jetzt
die Voraussetzungen um eigentlich in
Zukunft wieder in der Serienfunktion
Fertigung kostengünstler
das ist für mich vor einem Jahr
Vermehrung gegeben
er war da hatten russland hat in der
Ukraine hat er gekämpft es war furchtbar
also keiner möchte es haben wir müssten
jetzt nur sagen ihr müsst jetzt da bin
ich bei ihm wir müssen jetzt warten
liefern um den Druck zu erhöhen wir
müssen aber gleichzeitig alles dafür tun
dass wir versuchen einen Kompromiss zu
finden war so ist es ein humanitäres
Desaster für beide Seiten und das ist
einfach deine Dramatik Väter eine exit
Strategie wenn man noch weiter schaut ja
Essen Gegner
vor einem Jahr warum hat das nicht
geklappt vor allem ja ganz einfach falls
es nicht wollte ganz einfach man musste
Scholz immer zu den Entscheidungen
hintragen es war einfach teilweise schon
eine Peinlichkeit aber man musste Mann
heißt vielleicht sogar die Opposition na
ja vielleicht auch nicht also nicht ihre
aber eher das Ausland Polen z.B und
Strategie hervorragend ja ähm und ich
bin also dass das soll jetzt auch nicht
falsch liegen ich bin nicht für Krieg
also wer ist denn schon für krieg ich
meine das ist ja wie ich bin für Armut
also ja völlig unsinnig er Krieg ist
furchtbar Krieg ist grauenhaft Krieg ist
ich kann es mir nur vorstellen wie
schlimm ich war Gott sei Dank nie im
Krieg und hoffentlich werde ich es nie
erleben doch was noch schlimmer ist
zuzusehen wenn andere Länder oder andere
Menschen massakriert werden und wir
schauen zu und wir haben und hätten die
Möglichkeit das zu verhindern das ist
für mich noch viel schlimmer und das ist
eine typische relativ schlechte simple
Strategie der japassement Politik der
30er Jahre wohin die geführt hat wissen
wir alle bis nach Auschwitz genau aber
ich finde diese Hitler Vergleiche
wirklich
zuschauen nichts machen ein Land wird
angegriffen zuschauen nein wir sollten
was machen aber die Frage ist ja was wir
machen wenn wir immer mehr Waffen in ein
Pulverfass liefern schauen wir auch zu
dass immer mehr Menschen sterben also
wir schauen ja jetzt in dem Sinne auch
sowas machen wir wollen ja nicht
militärisch ein Waffenlieferungen
sterben die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
auch wenn wir einen wenn zum Beispiel im
Frühjahr nicht die Friedensgespräche
abgebrochen worden wären was sie von
ukrainischer Seite wurden wir hätten
vielleicht schon gar keine Menschen mehr
sterben müssen also wenn man einen
Waffenstillstand erreicht wenn man
Friedensverhandlungen erreicht dafür
muss man aber ein gewisses
Kompromissbereitschaft an den Tag legen
dann sterben die Menschen nicht mehr und
ich plädiere
ja also ich meine zurzeit hat sie Lenski
die Position das hat er in einem Dekret
hinterlegt das mit Russland nicht
verhandelt wird solange nicht der letzte
Russe von der Krim vertrieben wurde
Ukraine die Krippen befreien so das kann
man völkerrechtlich rechtfertigen es ist
nur militärisch der blanke Wahnsinn weil
die die Schwarzmeerflotte der Russen ist
nicht seit 2014 auf der Krimi die ist
seit dem 18 Jahrhundert auf der Krim und
alle Militär sind sich einig die Russen
würden eher Atomwaffen einsetzen als die
Krippen also das ist so das kann man
schrecklich finden ich am Ende auch also
jeder Einsatz auch nur die das Denken
Nachdenken darüber dass Atomwaffen
irgendwo eingesetzt werden sind ist ein
Menschheitsverbrechen trotzdem gibt es
diese Waffen und die Länder die über sie
verfügen man ist wurden schon zweimal
Atomwaffen eingesetzt nach dem zweiten
oder im Zweiten Weltkrieg und niemand
kann ausschließen dass das wieder
passiert und der damalige
hat er gesagt
ich finde das also das ist ja
unverantwortlich natürlich also
Atomwaffen einzusetzen das ist das
barbarische was man sich vorstellen kann
aber wir können doch trotzdem nicht
sagen okay die Drohnen nur man muss das
ja ernst nehmen und wie gesagt die
Militärs also auch er war z.B auch Herr
Kuja hat auch andere gehen davon aus ihr
die Russen die krim-räumen werden sie
die letzte Karte ziehen weil das für sie
ein ganz existenzielles Interesse hat
ist und ich kann mich auch erinnern zum
Beispiel der damalige Präsident der
US-Präsident kennedy hatte nach der
Kuba-Krise einmal etwas sehr sehr kluges
gesagt er hat gesagt man sollte eine
Atom macht nie in eine Situation bringen
haben sie nur die Auswahl hat zwischen
einer demütigenden Niederlage und dem
Einsatz von Atomwaffen einfach weil man
dieses Risiko nicht eingehen darf und da
frage ich mich eben auch was ist
schlimmer also ein Zugeständnis bei der
Krim beispielsweise oder aber auch der
Versuch zum Beispiel im Donbass die
Bevölkerung selbst unter UNO Aufsicht
entscheiden zu lassen sowas hat es ja
schon anderswo gegeben ich meine
Deutschland hat ein furchtbaren Zweiten
Weltkrieg vom Zaun gebrochen und in
krachen verloren trotzdem konnte das
Saarland danach in den 50er Jahren
entscheiden wollen wir zu Deutschland
gehören oder nicht so und sie haben sich
ja dann entschieden was damals nach
diesem furchtbaren Krieg der ist ja
wirklich noch eine andere Dimension
natürlich gewesen als der Ukraine kriegt
etwas damals möglich war muss doch auch
im Donnerstag möglich sein das heißt es
gäbe doch wirklich eine Möglichkeit wie
gesagt bei der Krim glaube ich muss mal
kompromissbereit sein da muss man auch
ehrlicherweise sagen die Krim
Bevölkerung nach allem was man weiß sind
jetzt nicht sich danach dass die Ukraine
sie wieder aber sich Angel gegliedert
also die haben schon 91 in einem
Referendum dafür votiert zu Russland zu
gehören also sie Krim würde ich
gesondert sehen im Donbass finde ich
wäre das beste die Bevölkerung zu fragen
wohin Sie wollen das geht aber nur wenn
der Krieg aufhört das geht nur wenn die
Waffen schweigen also sonst ist das
bedeutet aber auch dass die Theorie ist
das
Opfer unter Druck zu setzen bloß den
Täter nicht weiter zu reizen
ich finde was heißt das Opfer unter
Druck zu setzen also selenski ist das
Opfer eines oder die Ukraine und die
ukrainische Führung damit auch das Opfer
eines Angriffskrieges das ist richtig
aber sie werden auch mit zum Täter in
dem Augenblick wo sie keine
Kompromissbereitschaft zeigen ich meine
selenski hat auch eine Verantwortung für
die Bevölkerung und seinem Land und wenn
er sagt ich führe so lange Krieg bis ich
alle Gebiete zurückerobert habe dann
heißt das er nimmt in Kauf das wirklich
auf Dauer
dass die Ukraine zum Opfer wird wenn sie
keine Kompromiss bekommen
so wie eine Frau die vergewaltigt wird
sie sagt ja also aber wenn du keine
Kompromisse machst und so weiter dann
bist du auch mit Täter das kann ja nicht
wahr sein verantwortlich sind für seine
Bevölkerung schon ich finde er hat auch
eine Frieden
gleichzeitig keine Gleichsetzung es gibt
begonnen hat und es gibt einen der sich
jetzt in diesem Krieg Wert und trotzdem
ist es meines Erachtens so dass eine
Verantwortung hat auch vor seinem Land
und seiner Bevölkerung diesen Krieg
schnellstmöglich zu beenden
er verhandelt nicht bis die Krim befreit
ist dann heißt das ja
beenden und er nimmt in Kauf dass jeden
Tag ganz viele Menschen sterben und ich
finde dafür dass dafür hat er das Recht
nicht weil es gibt ja in der Ukraine
aktuell auch gar keine Opposition die
sich artikulieren darf es gibt die
Fernsehsender sind verboten die Parteien
sind verboten die Journalisten werden
zurzeit unter Zensur gestellt also es
ist ja nicht so dass eine lebendige
Debatte gibt und ich bekomme Post von
Ukrainerinnen und vor allem
Ukrainerinnen die Männer dürfen ja nicht
raus die z.B jetzt in Deutschland sind
und die mir schreiben sie machen sich
riesen sorgen sie haben wahnsinnige
Angst um ihre Männer die nicht raus
dürfen oder manchmal sind auch die Söhne
und sie wollen dass dieser Furcht dass
dieses sterbendet und es geht ihm nicht
um die Krim sondern es geht darum dass
endlich
irgendwie ein ein Frieden einzieht das
ist ein Waffenstillstand gibt und ich
finde auch selensky hat eine
Verantwortung genauso wie wir als Westen
weil wenn wir Waffen liefern sind wir
eben auch Teil dieses Krieges wir haben
auch eine Verantwortung alles dafür zu
tun dass endlich die Waffen schweigen
das sind nicht nur die Russen wir haben
es begonnen aber trotzdem ist der Westen
und die Ukraine in Verantwortung sehr
sehr schön bei uns Krieg gibt die
Diskussion weil sie haben natürlich
eigentlich haben beide beide haben
sie vollkommen Recht sie haben
vollkommen recht das ist furchtbar ist
so ist die Frage ist doch wie kommt man
aber raus da kommt noch dabei raus dass
wir schneller beide Seiten erkennen
dass es nicht mehr vorangeht wenn Putin
erkennt dass er keine Chance hat
irgendwie das zu halten und zu
verteidigen dazu müssen die Waffen
liefern gleichzeitig muss natürlich auch
die Ukraine erkennen dass das was sie
als Ziele formuliert ich realistisch ist
und das ist etwas wo ich halt sage es
wäre schöner wenn jetzt der wenigen
Farben müssen das sein wenn die USA
Druck aufbauen da ist auch auf die
Ukraine zu sagen so wir müssen weg gehen
wir können nicht diese diese Kette da
machen mit immer weiterer mit weiteren
haben weiß ich nicht und das bringt was
ich auch nicht aber das muss im Prinzip
was passiert und wie lange das nicht
passiert erleben wir einfach nur was Sie
wollen gesagt habe die Verlierer nutzen
und am Ende das Ende des Krieges durch
Erschöpfung und das ist einfach
furchtbar ist wie im ersten Weltkriege
Erschöpfung wo die Ressourcen
aufgebraucht sind wo die Menschen tot
sind und das ist ein Desaster und darum
ich bin dediziert andere Auffassung als
sie was die Waffenlieferung betrifft ich
finde das richtige Waffen liefern ich
bin aber definitiv dafür dass ich viel
mehr Druck ausüben müssen
das ist zwar zynisch aber es ist ja so
für die USA läuft ist gut sie
profitieren Sie profitieren als
Waffenlieferant sie profitieren als
Gaslieferant jetzt haben Sie endlich den
europäischen Markt das russische Gas ist
weg sie profitieren als
Wirtschaftsstandort da werden wir
nachher noch mal drüber reden und sie
profitieren weil die NATO jetzt wieder
ein absolutes Comeback hat und damit
ihre Führungsrolle also das heißt mein
Appell ist ja nur an die deutsche
Regierung an die europäischen Regierung
uns betrifft es wenn der Krieg sich
ausweitet ganz direkt er ist vor unserer
Haustür nicht vor der der USA die
europäischen Regierungen müssten die USA
unter Druck setzen und zumindest eine
deutliche Ansage machen wir liefern hier
nicht weiter Waffen wir wollen jetzt
endlich eine gemeinsame
Friedensinitiative erst dann glaube ich
wird das Weiße Haus reagieren weil zur
Zeit ist es ja offensichtlich noch nicht
mal so dass das Pentagon dort irgendwie
mit zu reden hat die waren ja auch gegen
die aber das Lieferungen trotzdem hat
beiden das entschieden also ich finde
schon interessant die Militärs sind
zurzeit die besondersten oder vielleicht
auch diejenigen die die gefahren haben
wie geht's weiter und das ist halt die
Frage mal eigentlich auch stellen muss
ich glaube halt einer ich kann jetzt ein
bisschen was die ganzen USA ein bisschen
verschwörungstheoretischer mal ein paar
Aspekten muss ich ihn in der Tat
zustimmen in der Tat ist es so die
Amerikas die großen wirtschaftlichen
Gewinner die Frage ist natürlich nur wir
hätten noch die Möglichkeit selber auch
es werden sie zynisch klingt natürlich
auch die Möglichkeit davon
wirtschaftlich zu profitieren also wenn
man Zukunft eine neue Panzer kaufen
müssen weil die alle kaputt sind ein
besser schwimmen wir würden in
Deutschland gefährlich werden würden
kann amerikanischen kaufen weil ich mal
ganz banal das ist jetzt ziemlich in dem
Zusammenhang verstehe ich nur es wird
sowieso kommen und wenn ich sowieso Geld
ausgeben muss dann noch bitte für
Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland als im
Ausland das heißt wir müssen in der Tat
in Europa und doch in Deutschland nie an
unseren Interessen denken und auch
unsere wirtschaftlichen Interessen
denken das machen wir zu wenig
denken wir auch und auch das leidet in
diesem Krieg die Kunst und die Kultur
anderthalb wo der große Opernstar wurde
jetzt ausgeladen in Wiesbaden darf sie
nicht auftreten Herr Plutz und sie
finden das ist eine falsche Entscheidung
ja unbedingt also ich habe das gestern
im Radio gehört im Bayerischen Rundfunk
und mir ist dieser Maßen ja die die die
die Gabel aus dem Mund gefallen weil das
kann wirklich nicht wahr sein was ist
passiert Wiesbaden hat einen jährliches
fest und an eine Treppe ist eingeladen
zum überraschen zum Singen so was ist
passiert der ich muss auf meine Hand
schauen denn er heißt Boris rein äh nee
Boris rein wenn Sie sich wundern wer das
ist keine Sorge ich muss auch nicht dass
der hessische Ministerpräsident er hat
wohl Druck ausgeübt und nicht nur er
sondern auch ein
Politiker im Stadtrat und einige in
Wiesbaden dass Sie doch bitte ausgeladen
werden sollte
Grund ja wahrscheinlich weil sie Russin
ist bestimmt auch nur halb sie ist auch
noch Österreicherin aber das ist auch
völlig egal kleiner Spaß Fakt am Rande
der gar nicht so spaßig ist Frau hat in
Russland Verbot aufzutreten weil sie den
Krieg kritisiert hat also es ist eine
Unglaublichkeit eine Art von cancel
culture die was viele Leute denken dass
sie gar nicht gibt aber sie gibt es die
sleibhaftig ich habe sie am eigenen
Leiter erfahren gerade wenn ich das
wieder kunst muss Kunst bleiben weil es
ist kein Politikum und vor allem auch
keinen haltungswettbewerb dass jeder mit
einer falschen Meinung oder sogar mit
einem falschen Nachnamen aus die
Grenzwert eine Unglaublichkeit also auch
für richtig wenn beispielsweise an eine
Treppe dort auftritt und im
Orchestergraben Spielen der Musiker aus
der Ukraine ja und auch aus Schweden
oder auch aus Nordkorea meinetwegen das
ist doch völlig egal es geht um die
Kunst es geht darum dass man schönen
Abend hat dass man mit seiner Liebsten
mit seiner Familie sich einen Konzert
anschaut es geht um Musiker die ihren
Beruf ausüben das könnte man auch über
Berufsverbot sprechen es gibt wirklich
schlicht um die Kunst nach diesem Motto
könnte man keinen was auch immer mehr
hören kein Wagner mehr alles weg weil
alles war ganz schlimm und so weiter und
Frau hat ja nichts sie hat ja nichts
Falsches gemacht oder wie die Leute so
schön sagen heute die hat nichts gemerkt
sondern sie hat einfach nur
sie ist einfach nur da sie ist einfach
nur da und heißt mit Nachnamen eine
Treppe das ist der einzige Grund
Geburtstag gefeiert also man kann hier
so ein bisschen eine Nähe wird ihr oft
unterstellt wenn ich damit sagen ich
habe mal in der schlimmsten Disco in
Unterfranken mein Geburtstag gefeiert
und ich liebe auch noch also
ganz schlimm also ich finde das wirklich
unterirdisch es ist ja ein Beispiel von
vielen also es ist ja in vielen Ebenen
also ich habe manchmal Diskussionen
gehört dass man irgendwie weiß ich nicht
russische Komponisten nicht mehr spielen
soll am besten vielleicht auch toll
nicht mehr lesen soll in den Schulen das
ist doch irre ich meine die russische
Kultur die ist Teil der europäischen
Kultur und die russische Literatur hat
auch unsere mitgeprägt das war ja eine
ganz enge Wechselwirkung und jetzt
werden ja auch ganz viele
Kulturprojekte eingestellt
Zusammenarbeit von Universitäten alles
wird auf Eis gelegt und ich finde das
wirklich grässlich das ist ein solches
banausentum und was mich wirklich auch
aufregt also diese ganze Wolke Szene wo
ist ja immer so diese diese Definition
gab also eigentlich ist es schon
Rassismus wenn man jemanden da danach
fragt wo er herkommt das ist ja
tatsächlich so eine Diskussion immer
gewesen man darf also niemand fragen wo
seine Herkunft ist bei Russen gilt das
alles nicht also bei Russen wird nicht
nur gefragt wo ihre Herkunft ist sondern
im Gegenteil sie werden weil sie eine
bestimmte Herkunft haben gar nicht weil
sie eine bestimmte politische Meinung
haben an den Rand gedrängt und
ausgegrenzt und ja also mir fehlt mir
jedes Verständnis also bei dem Punkt
muss ich ihn natürlich recht geben
auch mit vielen internationalen
Künstlern zusammen und das so weit dass
bei ihnen irgendwann der passt quasi
darüber entscheidet mit wem sie
zusammenarbeiten
darauf antworte ich gerne aber ich habe
heute mit meiner zwölfjährigen Tochter
über dieses Thema gesprochen und meine
Tochter sagte ad hoc genau das gleiche
das ist doch Rassismus was hat die denn
falsch gemacht ja einen zwölfjähriges
Kind
wir haben 15 lizenz-tanzschulen in
Deutschland ich habe für mehr als 200
Künstler international und national
gearbeitet wir haben unglaublich viele
Choreographen Coaches Tänzer über
Deutschland verstreut es gibt Ukraine es
gibt Russen es gibt Asiaten es gibt
deutsche alles Amerikaner es ist egal es
gibt bei uns kein Unterschied den wir
machen aufgrund der Herkunft sondern bei
uns ist der Unterschied hast du eine
Leidenschaft zum Tanzen kannst du das
gut dann kannst du in den
professionellen Bereich wenn ich bleibst
du in dem halb professionellen Bereich
und hältst du dich an unsere Regeln aber
ich kann doch nicht sagen okay dein Name
z.B eine Russin bei uns heißt Tanja ja
ich kann doch nicht sagen du bist Tanja
und mit Nachnamen heißt du wenn ich
jetzt nicht so und so deswegen kann ich
dich nicht in meine Schule lassen also
was was ist das denn und gerade die
Ampel sagt doch immer Wladimir Putins
brutaler Angriffskrieg nicht der
Angriffskrieg der Russen also was hat
denn ein Russe der das nicht mit
entschieden hat damit zu tun dass die
Ukraine und Russland im Krieg sind wie
läuft die Zusammenarbeit dann beim
Tanzen zwischen Russen und Ukrainern da
gibt es überhaupt keine Befindlichkeiten
also bei uns wirklich vielleicht ist es
woanders anders aber wir tanzen die
unterhalten sich auch Russisch
Ukrainisch sorry ja ich kann ein
bisschen russisch aus der DDR Schule
noch damals aber unterhalten sich
miteinander oder unterhalten sich
englisch oder deutsch es gibt keine
Unterschiede bei uns ist wirklich diese
diese Community steht für tanzt und das
ist unsere Sprache das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen schönerisch aber genau das ist
es bei uns wird niemand ausgegrenzt die
verantwortlich ist die Frage wie will
man den Frieden gestalten eigentlich wir
müssen noch es wird dann irgendwann
Frieden geben hoffentlich sicherlich und
dann müssen doch lieber miteinander
leben wir können ja nicht jetzt hunderte
lange für Feindschaften aufbauen ich
meine nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg da
wurde dann eben diese ganzen
Städtepartnerschaften was gemacht wurde
und die deutsch-französische
Freundschaft und austauschen und so
weiter und im anderen fand ihre Frage
bisschen befremdlich wenn sie sagen wenn
da Orchestermusik aus der Ukraine sind
und die Treppe singt ja wenn die die
müssen noch
weiter haben und miteinander reden
können desto besser ist doch die Basis
argumentieren die Veranstalter
fahren eigentlich die Völker
Verständigung und wenn wir jetzt
sozusagen so komplette Grenzen machen
ich meine dann haben wir hier die legen
wir die Grundlage von Konflikt da leben
wir alle schon lange nicht mehr 100
Jahren da sitzen wieder durch alle Leute
diskutieren bei keine Ahnung
ja auch anders gehandhabt also nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg oder zumindesten
Jahrzehnten danach also deutsche
Literatur wurde da immer gelesen ich war
immer erstaunt ich habe als Schülerin im
weimar am Goethehaus Führung gemacht und
wir hatten da auch russische Gruppen
also Touristen und das war immer
erstaunlich wie gut die informiert waren
also das heißt Goethe Schiller wurde in
der Sowjetunion Russland also
wahrscheinlich auch in den anderen
Sowjet Republiken wurde gelesen das war
also Teil auch der Kultur und wir machen
jetzt also und ich meine die hätten
wirklich viel Grund gehabt zu sagen also
das ist jetzt hier das war ja ein ein
grauenvoller auch Vernichtungskrieg von
wo Millionen umgebracht worden und
trotzdem haben sie sich kulturell
geöffnet und was wir jetzt hier machen
ist wirklich nicht verstanden also
überhaupt nicht zu verstehen immer mehr
Unternehmen waren dann ab das ist gleich
unser Thema nach einer ganz kurzen Pause
bleiben Sie dran weil Villach 8 bis
gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht holen hier ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner Ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist
das fast total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Staaten werden
die alle wegfallen und wir uns
gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos
verkaufen das funktioniert nicht dann
ist alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss noch
was machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über dem Gerät
[Musik]
schön dass Sie bei uns sind die
Bundesregierung die verbreitet
Optimismus Wirtschaftskrise von wegen ja
mein Blick sogar ganz wohlwollend auf
das laufende Jahr Daniel steht da sieht
das ganz anders und erklärt uns warum
das kann ich gerne probieren also es ist
so in der Tat die Wirtschaft sollen die
schrumpfen im kommenden Jahr das ist die
gute Nachricht die Regierung lobt sich
am meisten lobt sich ja habe ich selber
und sagt es ist doch super seine
Maßnahmen hätten uns alle gerettet ich
glaube in der Tat was sind gerettet hat
ist die Anpassungsfähigkeit der
deutschen Wirtschaft die enorm Gas
gespartner die wiedergewiesen hat die
widerstandsfähig ist das Problem der
ganzen Sache ist unsere Politiker denken
die wäre so widerstandsfähig man kann
allem Blödsinn mit ihr machen
Energiekosten hoch Sozialabgaben hoch
co2-abgaben hoch sie kennen den ganzen
Themen Bürokratie die Wahrheit ist aber
in internationalen Vergleichsstudien
rutscht Deutschland immer weiter nach
hinten der Standort Deutschland wird da
hinten durchgereicht und die Firmen
Stimmen ab die BASF investiert nicht in
Deutschland sondern in China den USA sie
wird in Deutschland Barriere
Arbeitsplätze wäre 10.000 Personen
abbauen die Bayer AG forscht nach neuen
Medikamenten nicht in Deutschland wegen
der Regulierung und selbst biontech
unser Großer corona-star hat jetzt
bekannt gegeben die Forschung für
Krebsmedikamente lieber in England zu
machen was mir vorstellen brexit England
die gehen nach England und sind nicht
bei uns und über Regierung sagt alles
ist super wir machen nicht sondern wir
machen weiter wir bisher mit Regulierung
mit Staatswirtschaft mit Umverteilung
und so weiter wir reden vermögensabgaben
höhere Steuern die ganzen Themen und was
passieren wird es folgendes wir werden
ein Wohlstandsverlust erleben und das
sagt jetzt nicht nur gesagt die Kriege
wieder Aufbau eines Staatsbank hat diese
Woche gewahr stehen vor einem Jahrzehnte
wohlstandsvernichtung eigentlich
aufgrund von Demografie von diesen
ganzen Faktoren und die Regierung sagt
wir machen nichts wir machen schlimmer
und weiß natürlich weiß was sie tut
ändert da habe ich noch den Maßstab mit
dem Mist bei normalerweise ein bisschen
mehr Wirtschaftsleistung nach dem
proteinsatzprodukt also ganz einfach
gesprochen nach allem was er verdient
und nachdem wir in Zukunft weniger
verdienen haben werden als jetzt sagte
auch wir haben auch andere Bakterien
Nachhaltigkeit Gerechtigkeit und wir
kennen das ja alle wenn Sie viele Ziele
vereinbaren paar Ziele werden sie schon
erfüllen und so aber die Regierung heute
an der Kaschierung der Probleme an der
Kaschierung der Folgen der eigenen des
eigenen Handels Stichwort Energiepolitik
um so zu tun als wäre alles schön und
gut Problem eine ganze Sache ist mein
letzter Satz es gibt in der Geschichte
kein einzigen Fall wo eine Bevölkerung
glücklicher wo geworden ist weil sie
einmal geworden ist und meine These ist
auch die deutschen wenn ich wirklicher
werden und sie werden dann auf Begehren
das Problem dann ganze Sache ist wenn
sie auch Begehren ist die Wirtschaft
schon lange weg weil die stimmt bereits
ab investiert im Ausland die verlagert
und das ist meine Kritik und darüber bin
ich heute traurig ist kein großer Freude
als ein Grund zur Traurigkeit weil wir
wieder mal Geschichten erzählt bekommen
von unseren Medien und von den
Politikern die einfach nicht stimmen
ganz konkret Herr Stelter das glauben
Sie wie steht Deutschland Ende des
Jahres da Ende des Jahres Wissen Ende
des Jahres ist natürlich irrelevante
Frage das hängt davon ab dass der Krieg
zu Ende kommt der gastfreies runter die
Frage interess ehrlich gesagt nicht was
interessiert Sie denn am Ende erzählst
da bei solchen ganz ehrlich deutlich
schlechter als heute die Firmen wandern
ab wegen der Energiekosten die Waren ab
wegen der Bürokratie die waren wieder
Steuerlast der wird Frau Wagen gleich
wieder sprechen aber sind egal die haben
ganz andere Prioritäten und deshalb
werden wir am Ende des Jahrzehnts werden
wir erleben dass wir viel weniger
Wohlstand haben dass sie geprägt sind
von massiven Verteilungskonflikten die
wir nicht mal leicht lösen können da
kann man nicht mehr einfach sagen wir
machen eine Steuernummer bis dahin
gestiegen wie mir gestiegen sein er
werden einfach sehen dass wenn Illusion
hatten von guten Zeiten und wir haben
die guten Zeiten ist meine Kritik eine
Regierung Merkel habe ich immer schon
formuliert letzten 20 Jahre wenn nicht
genutzt und vorzubereiten die
Infrastruktur ist schlecht die Bildung
ist schlecht die Bundeswehr taugt nichts
alles liegt dann nieder und wir haben 30
Politiker die obwohl der Tatsache
gesprochen obwohl der Staat seinen Job
nicht hinbekommt glauben sie könnten
noch besser steuern als selber kann das
kann nur schief gehen also es spüren sie
wird wird
spüren Sie die Krise Spinnen sie auch in
den Tanzschulen mit den Menschen mit
denen sie arbeiten spüren sie dass ich
etwas verändert habe wir haben ja
tagtäglich natürlich mit den Sorgen zu
tun und natürlich wenn du Klimakrise
hast wenn du Energiekrise hast wenn du
in Krieg hast in der Ukraine wenn wir
gerade aus der Pandemie kommen auch die
Denkweise der Menschen auch in unseren
Tanzschulen und generell wird ja negativ
fokussierter viel viel mehr als vorher
ja manchmal spiegelt die Realität und
sagen Sie auch gerade die jetzige
Realität spiegelt ja gar nicht das
wieder wie es in Wirklichkeit werden
wird und dadurch reagieren vielleicht
die Bürger auch noch nicht so verärgert
oder intensiv weil es geht uns ja noch
verhältnismäßig gut und so ist es auch
mit meinen Tanzschuhen und mit den
Firmen es geht uns verhältnismäßig gut
aber wenn ich keine ab oder hat
Existenzsorgen oder sie merken dass also
ganz ehrlich zu sein wir sind ja in
Deutschland in doch leider in einer
Neidgesellschaft aber ich sag das mal
ganz ehrlich bei uns haben wir im
Augenblick ein sehr sehr starken Zulauf
über in allen Tanzschulen und auch
insbesondere in bei uns in Berlin warum
weil die Leute aus diesem grauen Alltag
aus diesem negativ orientierten Alltag
in der Woche einmal eine Stunde oder
zwei Stunden einfach ausbrechen wollen
tanzen wollen Spaß haben wollen
Wertschätzung erfahren wollen und mit
einem Lächeln rausgehen wollen klingt
total banal aber das ist der Grund warum
bei uns gerade so die Post abgeht
übrigens goldene 20er Jahre
gemacht obwohl es eine echte Misere war
das passt ja und vieles kommt ja auch
erst noch also klar die die vorabschläge
sind da die meisten Leute wissen dass
ich Ihre Energiekosten verdoppeln werden
in diesem Jahr das weiß man schon trotz
aller bremsen aber was die
wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen sind das
kommt ja schleichend und ich sehe auch
dass wir tatsächlich im Grunde das
Rückgrat unseres Wohlstands verlieren
könnte und das ist vor allem der
industrielle Mittelstand und eben ja na
klar machen indem wir einfach bestimmte
Voraussetzungen nicht mehr schaffen und
nicht mehr gewährleisten und da sind die
einen die abwander aber es gibt ja auch
viele die gar nicht abwandern können die
etwas kleineren die aber trotzdem den
Wettbewerbsdruck haben also weil sie ja
ausländische
importieren ja vieles wenn das unter
viel günstigeren Bedingungen produziert
wird dann verschwinden die einfach vom
Markt oder es gibt die die kleineren
Unternehmen die eben hiesige
Konsumbedürfnisse erfüllen wollen und
dann ich habe ja zum Beispiel Bäcker
habe ich gesprochen auch mit Handwerkern
und die einfach jetzt sehen ja klar wenn
die Leute weniger Geld haben woran spart
man kann das Brot bei Aldi kaufen das
schmeckt schlechter aber es ist viel
viel billiger wie würden Sie die
Wirtschaft angucken recht also ich will
jetzt in der Regierung werden was würde
passieren also ich finde dass wir alles
tun müssen dass die Energiepreise wieder
runter gehen wir müssen uns um billige
Energie kümmern da einfach so zu tun und
das ist ja halbwegs Strategie auch
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht da
müssen alle nur sparen ich meine das
Absurde ist ja klar kann man die
Klimaziele dadurch erreichen dass die
ganze Industrie nicht mehr da ist also
wenn wir uns die industrialisieren haben
wir die Klimaziele in Deutschland
erreicht ja großartig
zweiten Punkt ich möchte einmal kurz bei
der Energiefrage einhalten 14 neue
Atomkraftwerke will Frankreich jetzt
warum sind sie da neidisch ja muss ich
mal wirklich sagen wir haben noch sechs
die einigermaßen laufen laut Manfred
haferburg ist auch möglich also die
laufen können laut Manfred Harburg
ordentliche Kenner davon er meinte ja
bei 220 unsicher aber es könnte
funktionieren ja ich bin neidisch kannst
auch ganz einfachen Grund wenn man
richtig und wenn man sich das wenn man
schon dieses auf diese Klima Frage
eingeht dann kann man sich ganz genau
anschauen ab wann war die Bilanz von
Frankreich besser in dem Moment als sie
Atom mit Atomstrom ähm genau das kann
man sich ganz genau anschauen das ist
ganz ganz simpel versteht sogar ich und
wenn man ähm ja aus aus Braunkohle
aussteigt auf Steinkohle aussteigt und
auch Atomkraft aussteigt ja Mai und das
Gas ja aus aus Gründen nicht mehr fließt
von Russland wobei auch da könnte die
Frage stellen warum
ja was bleibt denn da übrig dann muss
man es importieren und glaubt man
tatsächlich letzter Satz ist Deutschland
wirklich so verblödet entschuldigung das
Wort dass sie von aus allen
grundlastfähigen Energiequellen
aussteigt und dann glaubt dass die
Nachbarländer
bezahlen
wer wir importieren Kohlestrom
also ich glaube nicht dass das in
Zukunft nicht nur die ist und sag mal
die Stimmung wird in dem Augenblick
wieder kippen wenn es irgendwo ein
Störfall gibt ich bin dafür jetzt diese
drei Meiler am Netz zu lassen weil alles
andere ist ja Wahnsinn wir könnten
viel viel mehr Geld investieren müssen
für die Forschung in Fragen
Fusionsreaktoren also Technologien die
nicht so gefährlich sind also beim
Atomkraftwerk ist eben tatsächlich das
Problem
es ist nicht gelöst was macht man mit
dem Müll der daraus kommt keiner will
ihn haben dann schieben wir ihn irgendwo
nach Afrika nach einer schönen Dank dann
haben wir weit weg keiner will auch in
der Nähe eines Atomkraftwerks leben also
ich meine Folgen zum Beispiel im Saal in
der Nähe von catenom ich würde sagen ich
schlafe ein bisschen ruhiger wenn es das
nicht mehr gäbe sein altes Atomkraftwerk
also aber trotzdem ich finde wir müssen
auch bei Gas Gas ist zum Beispiel als
Brückentechnologie besser weil man das
nämlich hoch und runter regeln kann also
wenn man zum Beispiel erneuerbare
Energien hat wenn die sehr viel Strom
bringen dann kann man Gas runter regeln
man kann es aber sehr schnell wieder
hochziehen das geht bei Atom gar nicht
und was ich aber für die puren Wahnsinn
halte ist so zu tun wir müssen nur noch
ein paar Windräder aufstellen und ein
paar Solar Dächer und dann haben wir das
Energieproblem gelöst das ist völlig
irre weil das in unserem breiten aktuell
so ist im Winter ist es eben oft dunkel
und Wind Arm und dann haben wir dann
nützt es nichts wenn wir die ganze
Landschaft vorne ja wir hatten das ja im
Dezember z.B da hat einfach das
erneuerbare
energisch ne auf Frankreich oder oder
ist es so es gibt zwar neue Generation
von Atomkraftwerken wo die Probleme
nicht mehr so sind aber die brauchen
jetzt gar nicht so diskutieren wir haben
vor wir haben Atomkraftwerke die Körper
laufen lassen der denn unmittelbar
wirken aus auf die Energiepreise das
nicht zu tun ist irre sein immer weiter
denken müssen sagen was passiert ist
folgendes Deutschland ist was die den
CO2-Ausstoß betrifft relative
Wirtschaftsleistung sind wir sehr sehr
gut wir haben 0,15 Tonnen pro 1000
Dollar brutto für die Zahl die Franzosen
sind besser 0,1 den Atomkraftwerke wir
haben uns deutlich gemacht die
einzigsten eigentlich der einzige
wirklich alles verfehlt hat heißt immer
Verkehr stimmt aber gar nicht würden wir
die Atomkraftwerke laufen lassen und
hätten die Kohlekraftwerke zugemacht
stünde wir viel viel besser da jetzt
stehen wir schlechter die Politik ist ob
wir stehen so schlechter Zielen und
erhöht den Druck auf die Wirtschaft noch
maximaler also die Wirtschaft die
eigentlich was gemacht hat bekommt dann
noch mal einen auf den Deckel wir Bürger
bekommen alle auf dem Deckel es gibt
Zahlen von 19 Jahren die Sagen um die
Immobilien bestanden
energetisch zu erneuern das kostet 3000
Milliarden Euro
jetzt sagen wir bitte mal wo kommen die
3000 Milliarden Euro her in den nächsten
zehn Jahren so sind ganz andere machen
sollen es ist einfach man sieht schon es
ist einfach irre deshalb habe ich eben
aufhören Wohlstand zu messen weil er
nämlich gerade Wohlstand vernichtet
richtige Antwort wäre Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen in der
erneuerbare ausbauen und beim Stichwort
gasrollerwagen kann wir wissen wir holen
heute Gas aus Katar und sonst wo die
wird es wird klimaschädlichst über die
Welt geschippt also die Boote
verbrauchen dann die Hüfte das ist
glaube ich das was der ganze Kfz-Bestand
in Deutschland pro Jahr verbraucht
statt hier in Deutschland selber Gas zu
fördern können mich Gas fördern wir
können Fracking betreiben sagen alle oh
flecking ist ganz schlimm da gibt es
Filme aus USA es stimmt aber nicht ich
habe in meinem Podcast gesprochen
genau
es gibt schon Zweifel also man man pumpt
ja einen ziemlichen giftmix in den Boden
mit dem Thema man das hinterher genau
ich habe mich beschäftigt
Bundeswehr sauber als das was da unten
ist eine Entwicklung stärker geworden
wir tun so bloß nicht bei uns Atomkraft
in Frankreich
wir machen diese Illusion wir tanzen uns
die Welt schön
entschuldigen
die Welt schön und währenddessen
demonstrualisieren wir und in 10 Jahren
haben wir wie Wohlstand nicht mehr wir
haben es Klima nicht gerettet wir werden
weiter Kohlekraftwerke laufen lassen
müssen weil wenn ich keine anderen
Quellen haben und wir werden der große
Verlierer sein und alle gucken rüber
sagen wisst ihr noch wie Deutschland
früher mal war Lachnummer und die Jugend
ist die jugendwandert mich auch aus
nicht nur die Firmenwagen aus sondern es
gehen 200.000 Leute pro Jahr verlassen
das Land also überwiegend die Jüngeren
und die gut ausgebildeten die wir
verlieren es ist einfach ein Irrsinn und
dann wird sie von der Regierung erzählt
alles ist super das ist mein Problem
Wirtschaftsminister wenn sie mal in die
Regierung kommt also auf jeden Fall
finde ich es ganz wichtig dass man diese
Probleme wirklich jetzt in den
Mittelpunkt stellt also ich meine diese
habe ich der hatte
Wirtschaftsministerium geflutet mit
irgendwelchen grünen Beamten und
Staatssekretären die sich überwiegend
durch völlige Inkompetenz auszeichnet
und die ganzen Gesetze die gemacht
werden also das sagen ja das sagt ja
nicht nur ich das sagen Leute wirklich
die auch damit zu tun haben die sind
auch handwerklich schlecht und so
wirtschaften wir wirklich unser Land
kaputt also ich sehe da das
Energieproblem ich sehe allerdings
übrigens auch das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen da sind die da hat
er auch ein Erbe übernommen was er nur
weiterführt wir haben eine schlechte
Infrastruktur in Deutschland die
öffentliche Infrastruktur was
Straßenbrücken digitale Infrastruktur
Funknetze wir sind teilweise schlechter
als viele Entwicklungsländer also da
hätte längste weil man immer irgendwie
unter dem Stichwort wir müssen alle
sparen und der Markt macht das besser
der Staat hätte es machen müssen und da
hat es nicht gemacht das ist auch ein
richtiger Standort Nachteil dann haben
wir darüber haben wir knapp gesprochen
vorhin das Bildungssystem also das halte
ich wirklich ich meine warum hat China
so stark in den letzten 20 Jahren
aufgeholt gibt's viele Gründe wir haben
auch eine sehr geschickte
Wirtschaftsmodell gefunden also
Zusammenwirken statt und Wirtschaft aber
sie haben vor allem ein wirklich gutes
Bildungssystem sie haben einen
naturwissenschaftlich technisch
orientiertes Bildungssystem wo die Leute
wirklich was lernen wo es nicht so sehr
vom Elternhaus abhängt wo Leute
gefördert werden viele Punkte
in der Zukunft äh jetzt haben wir uns
aber gleich die Zukunft wirklich schon
erstellt haben 50% der jungen Chinesen
für die Schüler sind wieder
top-leistungsgruppe Mathematik in
Deutschland sind es unter 5 %.
um einigermaßen normal rechnen zu lernen
jetzt gesagt er möchte dass alle
englischen Kinder bis zum Schulabschluss
Mathematik machen müssen also Mathematik
aufzuwerden und England ist heute schon
viel besser als Deutschland der
Mathematik in diesen Test vergleichen
wir brauchen mehr Mathematik wir
brauchen höheres Bildungsniveau wir
müssen auch eigentlich anerkennen nicht
alle sollten studieren das dürfte nicht
so viele werden sozialwirtschaften oder
Betriebswirtschaft ausgebildet werden
brauchen wir nicht mehr gibt's genug sie
haben schon Betriebsrat brauchen mehr
Ingenieure wir brauchen mehr Handwerker
wir müssen dafür nicht Umsteuern wir
müssen auch aufwerten müssen auch die
besser bezahlen das auch gehört auch mit
zur Wahrheit dazu nur wir hatten ist auf
dem völlig falschen Kurs haben mich
völlig falschen Diskussion wir haben wir
diskutieren Themen die nicht relevant
sind und währenddessen
auf jeden Fall auch kaufen
auf jeden Fall brauchen ist mehr
Lebensmut und mehr Freude und sich auch
die Dinge schön tanzen liegt
hinterlassen bei uns allen Corona wir
saßen alle in der Bude und keiner wusste
mehr so richtig die motiviere ich mich
wie komme ich aus dieser Spirale die nur
nach unten zieht eigentlich wieder raus
und da hat Detlef D soost jetzt für uns
die Antwort und die heißt ich glaube ich
kannst du sagen scheiß drauf ne ja
scheiß drauf machst einfach das könnte
man in meiner Sprache sozusagen so sagen
aber was ich eigentlich sagen möchte ist
wir sollten wieder ein Perspektivwechsel
vornehmen wir sollten uns wieder mehr
ins Positive mindset bewegen das klingt
alles sehr blumig was ich jetzt sage
weil es aber eigentlich auch sehr
einfach ist durch die Klimakrise durch
den Krieg durch Corona sind wir Menschen
ja durch die Nachrichten und durch die
Medien fast täglich in dem negativen
mindset festgehalten wir hören nur
Grusel Nachrichten so und wenn wir das
auch noch in unserer normalen Alltag mit
reinnehmen dann wie sie sagen geht die
Spirale weiter runter das was ich sage
und das Phänomen des Anfang des Jahres
also der Januar ist ja immer der Monat
wo alle sagen okay jetzt nehme ich meine
großen Vorsätze jetzt setze ich das um
dass ich abnehme dass ich gesünder esse
dass ich mich beruflich verändere was
auch immer
und das Interessante ist dass schon nach
14 Tagen im neuen Jahr
97% der Menschen die gute Vorsätze haben
diese wieder fallen lassen nur über drei
Prozent ziehen es durch und dafür gibt
es ganz klare Gründer einmal dass man
von sich selbst zu wenig positiver
Erwartungshaltung hat und das zweite ist
die Menschen haben meistens kein klares
Ziel also die sagen ich nehme jetzt mal
abnehmen weil es ist auf Platz 1 der
guten Vorsätze die sagen nicht ich
möchte in 10 Wochen 20 Kilo abnehmen
sondern wir sagen dieses Jahr wäre ich
jetzt mal jetzt fange ich mal ein
bisschen abzunehmen das zweite ist sie
haben keinen Plan selbst wenn Sie ein
Ziel haben machen sie sich keinen Plan
wenn ich sage okay in zehn Wochen möchte
ich gerne 20 Kilo abnehmen dann muss ich
mir einen Plan machen muss ich in einer
Woche zwei Kilo abnehmen und am Tag 285
Gramm habe ich den Plan nicht ist das
Ziel riesengroß und ich gehe bei ihm er
beim ersten Gegenwind auf und das dritte
und das ist meiner Ansicht nach
entscheidend und da geht's nicht nur um
abnehmen oder um gesünder leben sondern
auch um berufliche Perspektiven um die
innere Balance mit sich selbst das
Commitment uns fehlt das Commitment und
selbst gegenüber wenn man sagt okay ich
habe das und das Ziel dann muss ich mich
auch mehr selbst gegenüber verpflichten
dass ich das so lange verfolge nicht bis
die Zeit um ist sondern bis ich das Ziel
erreicht habe und das ist das was ich
sehr gerne kommuniziere nicht nur in den
Tanzschulen sondern auch in Vorträgen
und das ist das Thema was ich heute
mitgebracht habe Frau wagenbeck können
Sie auch zu den 97 Prozent haben sich
irgendwas vorgenommen nicht eingehalten
nee also so richtig viele vorgenommen
also ist aber die Sachen die ich mir für
dieses Jahr vorgenommen habe die sind
noch nicht abzurechnen die sind erst
eher für den Herbst geplant
aber ich sag mal so ich glaube ich bin
was Selbstdisziplin angeht noch
einigermaßen also versuche ich mich zu
strukturieren aber ich verstehe das
natürlich auch immer viele Leute haben
ja auch ein enormen Stresslevel also
weil einfach jetzt ganz viel
zusammenkommen ne man hat man hat einmal
die so ständig steigenden Preise da hat
man dann muss man dann auch schon wieder
gucken was kaufe ich überhaupt das ist
ja auch ernähre mich gesund klingt ja
immer gut abnehmen will muss man sich
gesund ernähren ja vieles was gesund ist
ist auch sauteuer also man muss es sich
was leisten können da muss man viel
Disziplin haben gerade wenn es einem
dreckig geht ich kenne das auch man ist
irgendwie müde abends man hatte den
ganzen Tag Stress und dann steht da
irgendwie eine ganze Tafel Schokolade
oder ein toller Kuchen ja man belohnt
sich auch also das heißt wenn man
irgendwie im Stress ist und im Druck ist
dann macht man auch Dinge die man dann
vielleicht bereut und ich glaube so
geht's einfach vielen Leuten total
legitim ja deswegen sage ich immer der
Weg zum Erfolg wenn wir jetzt über
gesunde Ernährung sprechen ist eine
Sinuskurve ist nicht linear das heißt es
geht mal hoch und mal runter ich habe
vor mittlerweile 10 Jahren 32 Kilo
abgenommen 14 Wochen gemacht das ist
nämlich auch faszinierend wenn man sie
früher sieht und heute sie sieht böse
Patricia auf meinem auf böse jetzt nicht
irgendein dicken Bild von mir zeigen
ganz kurz mein ganz kurz mal
aushaltendes Foto das wollen wir jetzt
trotzdem rein was ist denn Regie zögert
noch
was zu tun aber
nein aber wirklich meine es ist ein Weg
wie haben sie sich da motiviert also wie
baut man da dran genau das was ich
gerade gesagt habe ich hatte ein klares
Ziel und ich habe mit jedem darüber
gesprochen auch diejenigen die es nicht
hören wollten ich habe gesagt ich will
aufs Cover einer Fitnesszeitschrift und
dafür muss ich mindestens 20 Kilo
abnehmen das wollte ich in zehn Wochen
abnehmen und glauben Sie mir viele haben
über mich gelacht viele haben gesagt ja
so ist der Mario Bart hatte immer gesagt
der Dicke Tanzlehrer aus dem Osten ja so
niemand hat es geglaubt aber das hat
mich natürlich motiviert weiter zu
machen dann hatte ich einen klaren Plan
ich wusste was ich am Tag abnehmen muss
und ich habe eingepreist das ist auch
mal Niederlagen das ist Rückschläge gibt
also fragen Sie mal meine Kinder oder
meine Frau wie oft ist nachts passiert
ist das plötzlich auf dem Kissen ähm
Schokoladenflecken waren weil ich nachts
wie ein Zombie runter bin und unsere
Küche und das schokoladenfach der Kinder
aufgemacht habe und eine ganze Tafel Weg
gegessen habe aber wenn du diese
Rückschläge einplanst ja Erfolg ist
nicht mal runter dann bist du nicht
überrascht und gibt es nicht so schnell
auf weil du weißt okay war klar dass es
passiert weitermachen aber sonst kommt
das bei Ihnen an haben sie sich
irgendwas vorgenommen und fühlen Sie
sich jetzt motiviert wenn sie so diese
paar Stichpunkte die er so ist uns jetzt
reingegeben hat hören ja tatsächlich und
es ist wirklich ein gutes Thema weil
genau wie du gesagt hast es ist wichtig
ist nicht der wichtig keine Ahnung ich
möchte erfolgreich sein ich möchte viel
Geld verdienen das ist so konkret wie
möglich ich möchte in einer halben Jahr
das und das machen deswegen hat mir das
Beispiel nicht unbedingt wegen des
Fitness Magazins aber wegen der
Bildhaftigkeit gut gefallen ich möchte
dieses Fitness Magazin ich möchte keine
Ahnung bei dieser Zeitung publizieren
ich möchte
Ihre persönliche sehr privat
übersetzen
Visualisierung die du gerade ansprichst
ja was ich gemacht habe Leute haben
darüber gelacht ich habe mir aus einer
Fitness-Zeitschrift als ich angefangen
habe mit diesem Abnehmprozess
ein Bild von einem männlichen auch
dunklen fitnessmodel rausgerissen was
mit Badehose aus dem Wasser mit dem
Sixpack kam und hatte das dann immer in
meinen Portemonnaie mit drin und
manchmal habe ich im Flieger gesessen
Mittelsitz links ein Mann rechts ein
Mann und ich pack währenddessen dann
mein Bild aus und gucke mir die ganze
Zeit das Bild habe ich auch gemacht
du weißt was ich meine ja also diese
Visualisierung ist extrem wichtig nicht
was will ich nicht mehr sondern was ist
das was ich will was ist mein Ziel wo
will ich landen das ist doch als
Strategieberater das ist doch deine
richtige Strategie gute Strategie also
ich finde es super
ich bin auch toll ich bin versuche auch
was zu machen dass ich versuche ein
bisschen fitter zu werden aber deine
Frau hilft mir eine gewisse hinsichtlich
Vorbild dass sie immer
farblich machen in der Tat ich glaube
die Routine ich glaube das ist die
Routine ich stehe morgen jeden Morgen
früher auf und dann sage ich okay jeden
morgen mache ich das jetzt einfach jeden
nicht gemacht habe hole ich diesen Tag
nach das heißt ich versuche quasi immer
das abzuhaken gibt es auch Apps die
helfen können generell was einfach noch
toll finde wäre wenn Prominente
allgemein prominente sagen würden das
ist mein Fitnessziel ich mache bestimmte
Dinge dass Leute quasi folgen also quasi
dazu sagen sollen so direkt intensive
daraus deutschland wird fit war aber
nicht wenn du gute Idee und dann können
wir auf andere Bereiche auch noch
ausweiten und nicht daran körperliche
Gewicht verlassen das ist das neue Buch
das war nur noch gesehen denn wir haben
dich umsonst hier in der Sendung scheiß
drauf gesagt das ist halt einfach machen
und einfach loslegen
musst bleibst du in einer Passivität und
das ist frustrierend weil du nicht
wegkommst vom Fleck und und das
Frustration wenn du anfängst dich zu
bewegen ob es kleine Schritte oder sind
oder große ist mir egal aber wenn du in
die Bewegung gehst wenn du ins Handeln
kommst dann merkst du das Dinge sich
verändern und es gibt dir den Mut weiter
zu machen also einfach auch nicht so
viel drüber nachdenken unsere Vorsätze
hier bei 8:15 Uhr im übrigen ja
weiterhin offene Debatten für mich ich
hoffe das ist uns auch heute ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich bei meinen Gästen ich
bedanke mich bei Ihnen fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns morgen wieder bis dann
[Musik]